[Music]
shed a tear
for the dearly deported some far left
dems are pushing
to end targeted deportations of criminal
illegal immigrants
including suspected gang members like
those from ms-13
who've been tied to brutal killings
across the country which i guess would
make those felons anchor criminals
new york congressman alexandria
ocasio-cortez says
that's funny said this country
is at a quote racial reckoning i
mispronounced her name
that's funny as she joins 34 democrats
and demanding an immigration overhaul
including pulley pulling back on
targeting gang members for deportations
she's right these undocumented felons
are just coming here to commit felonies
that americans won't do themselves
aoc writes quote the definition of an
aggravated felony is a relic of the
racist war on drugs
adding the memorandum invites racial
profiling by presuming that an immigrant
is a public safety enforcement
and removal priority if they've been
convicted of an offense in which an
element was active participation
in a gang or someone older than 16 who
intentionally participated in a gang
okay take a breath the memorandum she's
criticizing says that we should
prioritize
the deportation of convicted criminals
who are
also gang members so where's the racist
part
was the guy who wrote the memo wearing
blackface at the time i must have missed
it
keep in mind these gang members mostly
prey on other central american
immigrants
with crimes including murder and child
prostitution we're not talking about
mixing recyclables or
misgendering a cashier these are bad
people doing bad things
so in aoc's world we can't put these
felons in prison
and we also can't deport them so what
should we do with them
give them their own shows on cnn i hear
they're hiring
[Applause]
so matt it always feels like the far
left like they hate
they they hate american citizens more
than they hate illegal
immigrant criminals and they would i
mean if you can't put them in jail
what do you do with that i mean and and
this is the the only category that
really you can currently deport if you
think about the
biden administration i mean they've
reversed every policy and this is kind
of the last thing that
we all agree on yes yes getting rid of
violent
gang members that are here illegally i
mean if that you know i've often said
that the two parties appear to be
attacking towards different goals
currently which is the first time in our
nation's history
and i think that's where this is the
example of it because this is a this
would be a
blanket amnesty and meanwhile the
southern border is just pouring in and
you don't think there's
people that are want to do bad things
you're this is you know that's
very pollyanna-ish it is it is i wish i
knew what that meant pollyanna
i always see it but i rarely got it out
i know i i always hear people say that
and i said naive it means naive tyrus i
think that's going to be very good greg
that said a very interesting thing about
like how the parties are going
this way it almost feels like we are
kind of entering this
phase of two different countries like
there's one that it's like okay fine the
these states will deal with their
immigration a different way than this is
these states
there's well well it's the states that
are furthest away
from where the problem is that have all
the great ideas
i couldn't agree more with aoc on this
one i think this is a great idea
i think we should get sally struthers
and do a little infomercial
you know for just six cents a day yes
you can adopt
again a gang member bring him to your
home
like take one shot here or see me no
more
he's three tear drops away from being a
new soldier you could bring him
out we could fly him into your
neighborhood yes he could
you know he could stay with you for just
six cents a day and your
youngest daughter yeah there
put a post but my point is if you
brought them
to their doorstep or their town yes this
would not be the thing they'd be like
they've got to go we've got to do
something we need a national guard we
need more police more
we got to do something yeah it's
interesting it's always fun for when
you're safe
in new york talking about what you need
to do in arizona and california
it's amazing it's two different
countries cat i think we're headed
towards a bifurcation a word i had to
look up today
i don't know what it means i don't know
splitting i don't even know what yeah so
i mean splitting okay great
well i don't know because i my views on
immigration right have always been you
know
any non-violent person who wants to come
contribute to our economy
should be able to do so um because i i
don't contribute to the economy is key
because i don't believe in a welfare
state period and that's always where
people on the left
have you know disagreed with me there
yeah and now apparently they're also
going to disagree with me on the violent
part
yes which is really truly shocking i i
don't i mean
it's not you i'm okay with
discriminating against violent
people yeah i don't like people who
commit violent crimes
i also thought it was interesting
because years ago when i was doing
stand-up there was a guy who i did stand
up with he was on some of the same shows
and he got caught with cocaine and he
got deported
right he was a white guy who got
deported back to london
so why would she would she call that an
injustice too or no
i don't know you lost your connection
yeah i am
that's not true she does not do drugs
she does not do drugs at all at least
right now while we're on set
afterwards it's another story all hell
breaks loose
uh i just do it off dr drew's head i
just
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just there's so many things that are
happening in this country right now i
don't understand where they're going
i i just think the homeless thing in los
angeles i i was asking someone who was
defending i said what what if they show
up on my
lawn or right they're like well that's
there we go what if they go into my
son's bedroom yeah well
exactly well i i don't understand what
the logic is it seems to be no logic no
no where we're going with this and
that's the part i find most distressing
because it just keeps
there it's never enough it's just beef
constantly i have a beef i have a beef
i have a beef right what are we trying
to do if i'm not an epidemiologist
nothing but
um i think it's my previous point
they're not affected
so they're talking from thousands of
miles away is that stuff that has
nothing to do with them because if they
were
in the mix they would not be saying that
she'd be the first one calling
there's gang members outside my house
not there's
new americans here with shotguns and
blades it's going to be great
i have to go yeah and by the way if you
make that phone call you're racist
this idea of moving now everything in
which you are concerned about in life
becomes racist
we've i mean what can you can no longer
protect yourself because that itself is
racist
it's just confusing yeah i want to get
it right but i'm confused how dare you
discriminate against a gang banger
doctor
i'll just be that racist guy with no
crime in my front yard i'll just beat
that
yes i'll take the heat yeah exactly
the trade-off is far superior all right
we gotta move on up next
a guy who was relieved of command for
his anti-marxist stand
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else